l'ordre du jour appelle merci Monsieur
ministre lors du jour appelle la
question orale de Monsieur Daniel
Laurent à madame la ministre de
l'écologie du développement durable et
de l'énergie Monsieur Laurent
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues ma question
porte sur la publication des décrets
d'intégration des ouvriers des parcs et
ateliers et montrent de ma ténacité à
suivre ce dossier puisque depuis 2010 il
s'agit de ma troisième question orale
qui par voie de conséquences n'a pas
obtenu de réponse définitive
je serai donc assez bref mais
l'intégration des ouvriers des parcs et
ateliers les OPA dans les cadres
d'emploi de la fonction publique
territoriale est prévue par la loi 2009
1291 du 26 octobre 2009 qui a transféré
les parcs de l'équipement au département
les articles 10 et 11 de cette loi
précise car la date du transfert de
compétence les oppa sont mis à
disposition à titre individuel de
l'exécutif de la collectivité
territoriale et que dans un délai de
deux ans à compter de la publication
d'un écréme Conseil d'État ceci seront
intégrés dans la fonction publique
territoriale or les décrets portant sur
les conditions d'intégration des
ouvriers des parcs et ateliers de la
fonction publique territoriale et les
droits pensions des ouvriers des parcs
ateliers sont toujours en attente de
publication
cette situation qui perdure préoccupe
bien sûr les personnels et les services
idoine des départements
le 9 mai dernier nous avions une
précision de Monsieur le Ministre ou de
Madame la Ministre pardon dans une
réponse une question écrite de notre
collègue Christian en ami et je cite la
réponse la publication du décret
d'intégration est suspendu dans
l'attente de la révision du projet de
décret de retraite les deux décrets sont
indissociables en effet une expertise de
la direction générale de
l'administration de la fonction publique
a mis en évidence que le dispositif
dérogatoire au droit commun de
double-retêtre retraite prévue par
l'article 11 de la loi de transfert de
2009 pension du fond spécial des
ouvriers des établissements industriels
de l'État pour la période d'activité
passée au sein de l'État et pension de
la Caisse nationale des retraites des
agents des collectivités locales à
partir de l'intégration dans la fonction
publique territoriale pouvait notamment
du fait des nouvelles dispositions
introduites avec la réforme des
retraites en 2010 se révéler
financièrement
pénalisant pour les agents
donc j'entends bien cette réponse mais
il n'en demeure pas qu'il convient
d'avancer sur cette problématique aussi
pouvait nous pouvez-vous nous préciser
le calendrier s'il vous plaît monsieur
le ministre de publication des deux
décrets avant de clarifier la situation
des opéras je vous remercie pour votre
réponse qui sera je le souhaite précise
tant pour les agents que pour les
collectivités qui attendent cela merci
merci Monsieur Laurent la parole est à
Monsieur Pascal Camphin mini chargé du
développement monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Sénateur je vous prie tout
d'abord de bien vouloir excuser madame
Delphine bateau qui est retenu au
Conseil des ministres de l'Environnement
de l'Union européenne dans ce dossier
comme dans bien d'autres malheureusement
l'actuel gouvernement a hérité d'une
situation qui n'avait pas été traitée
pas été réglée par le précédent
gouvernement
comme vous le rappelez la loi relative
au transfert au département de parc de
l'équipement et à l'évolution de la
situation des ouvriers des parcs et
ateliers date du 26 octobre 2009 le
ministre de l'Environnement de l'époque
avait annoncé la publication des deux
décrets d'applications que vous
mentionnez dans votre question pour 2010
ces engagements n'ont pas été tenus
Delphine bateau a considéré de son côté
qu'il s'agissait d'une question de
justice sociale et on a fait une
priorité de l'agenda social du ministère
de l'écologie
dès l'automne 2012 un nouveau processus
de concertation avec les organisations
syndicales a donc été engagée afin de
reprendre la discussion dans son
ensemble depuis lors les réunions se
sont enchaînées à un rythme régulier
cette concertation a débouché sur
l'ensemble sur l'examen de l'ensemble
des solutions possibles en matière de
régime de retraite point que vous
évoquez dans votre question
l'élaboration de la solution la plus
adaptée est en cours elle nécessitera de
revoir la rédaction de l'article 11 de
la loi du 26 octobre 2009 et Delphine
bato s'engage à l'inscrire au prochain
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale
l'objectif est de parvenir à la
publication des deux décrets en 2013
avec pour ambition d'ouvrir le droit
d'option des OPA le plus tôt possible
s'agissant du projet de décret
d'intégration des amendements on peut
être apportés dans le cadre de la
discussion avec les autres ministères
permettant de répondre à plusieurs
demandes notamment des organisations
syndicales
concernant le deuxième volet du chantier
la réflexion sur les compétences
spécifiques justifiant le recrutement
d'OPA une démarche d'analyse des
missions a été engagée
un examen des besoins opérationnels des
services est menée avec les directions
métiers et les opérateurs comme voie
navigale de France afin de bâtir une
vision prospective des ressources
humaines à moyen terme
il est nécessaire de réfléchir à des
modes de recrutement pérenne de
personnel disposant de compétences
spécifiques à des conditions de gestion
adaptées il s'agira également pour les
OPA aujourd'hui en activité d'engager la
réflexion sur la révision du décret
statutaire du 21 mai 1965
dans l'attente de l'aboutissement rapide
de ces évolutions Delphine bateau a
obtenu le recrutement à titre
exceptionnel de 88 OPA supplémentaires
pour exercer des fonctions techniques à
VNF à la direction générale de
l'aviation civile et à Météo France
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
Laurent
pour répondre merci monsieur le ministre
pour votre réponse Vous avez très
justement dit justice sociale mais je
crois que c'est le cas et puis il y a
aussi les collectivités qui attendent ça
pour justement régulariser toutes ces
situations donc j'ai bien compris que si
vos propos sont tenus et vont dans le
bon sens ça serait réglé normalement à
la fin de l'année alors tant mieux pour
pour les OPA et puis tant mieux pour les
collectivités merci merci Monsieur
Laurent